[Música]
Hola qué tal Bienvenidos a la entrevista
de France 24 hoy vamos a aprender los
motores de una manera literaria están
conmigo Tatiana Calderón la primera
mujer de latinoamérica en conducir un
auto de Fórmula 1 y también Gabriela
Cordero escritora autora de la niña más
veloz que el viento del libro inspirado
en la carrera de Tatiana Muchísimas
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros y
gracias a ustedes por invitarnos
este es un libro que yo particularmente
disfruté mucho porque es un libro que
tiene un mensaje muy bonito a raíz de
los inicios de la carrera de Tatiana en
donde hay un papel antagónico que son
Esas voces que tenemos todos en nuestra
cabeza voces que nos dicen que no
podemos hacer las cosas que son sobre
todo muy presentes Cuando alguien como
Tatiana es pionero en algo en lo que
hace son unas voces que en este caso se
escuchan con más fuerza quiero comenzar
preguntándole a cada una porque decidir
contar esta historia de esta manera y
centrado en esta parte de la vida de
Tatiana que son sus inicios
Sí para nosotros era fundamental
hablarle a una audiencia infantil
juvenil porque Tatiana quiere empezar a
seguir derribando bueno empezar no a
seguir derribando puertas para que las
niñas que vienen detrás de ella no le
sea tan difícil pasar por todos los
obstáculos por los que ya ha pasado
sí Para mí fue un proceso como Perdón
por la voz un proceso como de reflexión
cuando empezábamos a hacer nuestras
sesiones para para que Gaby pudiera
escribir el libro
me di cuenta de nos dimos cuenta de
todas esas Barreras y de que para que no
sigan pasando pues uno tiene que hablar
que está bien ser diferente que hay
muchas cosas que al final precisamente
la sociedad como que nos impone y y que
lo que uno tiene que realmente tener
presente es un objetivo un sueño y que
nada
te impida llegará a ese objetivo pero
pues si hay muchísimas barreras que
todavía tenemos que derrumbar y la mejor
forma de hacerlo era Era contando Cuáles
son para que precisamente pues las niñas
que vienen por detrás
Y muchos niños y niñas que que tienen
pues esas dudas pues no tengan que pasar
por esto me llama la atención tú tienes
30 años los acabas de cumplir cierto no
me equivoco tienes 30 años y en este
libro cuentas como ya desde muy niña
tienes que pelear con demonios internos
y es una carrera deportiva muy larga es
mucho tiempo teniendo que luchar contra
esos demonios Cómo es mantenerse en ese
en esa situación durante tanto tiempo y
además en alto rendimiento
sinceramente yo no me había dado cuenta
de todas estas barreras hasta que las
empecé a contar a Gabriela y ella me
decía pero como así que eso te pasa esto
te pasó y entonces vas reflexionando y
cayendo en cuenta porque muchas cosas
que me pasaban pues yo me las callaba o
creía que pues como yo era diferente
Pues eso debía ser normal así Y entonces
por eso creo que hasta ahora me estoy
dando cuenta de todas esas Barreras y y
por eso quería como contarlas para que
cada vez más los niños los padres la
gente que está en el ambiente Pues nos
dé la oportunidad de
dedicarnos a lo que más nos gusta pero
desde partiendo desde la equidad
volviendo lo que comentabas antes
Gabriela de que este es un libro que lo
pudiéramos encajar dentro de la
literatura infantil pero que es un
mensaje que llega a todas las audiencias
hay un mensaje de superación de
empoderamiento de cumplir dos metas de
romper barreras Cómo fue el proceso de
creación de la niña más veloz que el
viento Sí
esta historia inicia casualmente cuando
Tatiana se monta en un Cat por primera
vez a sus 9 años y en solo cinco minutos
se da cuenta de que ama la velocidad que
ama la adrenalina y que eso es lo que
ella quiere hacer por el resto de su
vida para mí eso fue
algo tan inspirador darme cuenta de que
una niña tan joven tuviera esa
determinación ese enfoque y como ella lo
va construyendo a lo largo de su carrera
de manera consistente porque si lo que
Tatiana tiene es y para mí fue también
muy
inspirador terapéutico revelador
reafirmante poder construir esta
historia porque me encontraron también
en un momento de vida en el que a pesar
de que a mí me ha gustado la escritura
desde que soy chiquita no me había
atrevido a hacerlo
de manera pública y creo que entre las
dos compaginamos muy bien esas dos
partes y creo que era muy importante
como queríamos hablarle directamente a
esas niñas que venían detrás de Tatiana
que el libro fuera una fuera literatura
infantil pero no que fuera tampoco como
biográfico autobiográfico memoria sino
que tuviera una historia detrás que
tuviera un componente literario
importante y que como hay un tema de
fondo como es tan tan difícil quizás a
veces hablar de estereotipos de género
queríamos que tuviera magia que tuviera
dinamismo que tuviera Aventura que
habláramos de los valores familiares y
que también que existieron recorrido por
toda Colombia para que la gente de toda
Colombia sintiera afinidad por todo lo
que ha hecho Tatiana a lo largo de su
trayecto de su trayectoria por lo que me
cuentan las dos suba por parte y parte
hubo un elemento casi terapéutico
haciendo este trabajo juntas no
contar esta historia como decíamos antes
es contar la historia de muchas mujeres
y darle voz a muchas mujeres que han
pasado por lo mismo en el movilismo pero
también En cuántas otras disciplinas y
creo que nos cruzamos en el momento
perfecto para poder darle voz a esas
mujeres que necesitan ser escuchadas a
ampliar todo el tema de la diversidad de
equidad de inclusión y y no callarnos
más porque porque no hace falta tenemos
que contar las historias de manera muy
honesta muy vulnerable Y eso es lo que
Finalmente nos hace fuertes
hay un mensaje en este libro Le quiero
preguntar a las dos y quiero comenzar
con Tatiana Cuál es el mensaje de cada
uno quiere llevar con este libro
pues yo creo siempre llevar el mensaje
de si uno tiene un sueño
si trabaja con gente alrededor que creen
en sí mismo si uno cree en uno mismo uno
no tiene que ponerse límites al final
los límites te lo pone la sociedad o la
gente que no te quiere ver crecer la
gente que se siente
vulnerable ante ti entonces como hacer
ese llamado a la juventud
o a la gente que tiene un sueño y que a
veces no se ha atrevido a perseguirlo Yo
quiero mandar ese mensaje de si se puede
cuando cuando uno quiere algo trabaja
duro
las cosas al final
se llegan a concretar un no O sea yo
siempre soñé con la fórmula uno con
nueve años pero pues uno lo ve muy lejos
no hoy en día dices digo pues qué bonito
ha tenido ese sueño de nueve años y
tener esa convicción de que no podía
lograrlo Gabriela del mensaje que tiene
este libro para ti creo que es no tener
miedo no tener miedo porque creo que el
miedo nos carcome a todos a no hacer lo
que realmente nos gusta hacer nos
subestimamos nos menospreciamos tenemos
miedo a cometer errores a hacer las
cosas mal y la verdad es que la única
forma de de perseguir sus sueños es
echándose el agua a pesar de que el agua
esté helada quiero hacer un paréntesis
para hablar ahora un poco del momento de
tu carrera por el que atraviesas Tatiana
acabas de empezar la europea alemán
series con el equipo virage ya tuvimos
la primera parada cómo te sientes en
este nuevo momento de tu carrera bueno
primero muy agradecida con
terpel con Karol G con escudería Telmex
y claro por la oportunidad de estar
compitiendo un momento en este año que
creí que no poder estar en las pistas
al teamvirage porque me ha dado un
asiento en el european series vengo el
domingo de estar compitiendo por primera
vez con ellos con mis compañeros de
equipo desafortunadamente uno de mis
compañeros un golpe muy fuerte el
viernes antes de la carrera se fracturó
dos costillas Nos tocó encontrar un
piloto reemplazo que no se había montado
el carro
pese a todo esto logramos terminar la
carrera a estar compitiendo contra mi
ídolo que que siempre ha sido Juan Pablo
Montoya y su hijo Sebastián Hay varios
pilotos de Fórmula 1 corriendo en esta
categoría Entonces es un nivel muy alto
y me da la oportunidad de seguir soñando
y creciendo como deportista me ha dado
el tiempo también de estar aquí
presentando el libro que detrás de
cámaras Nos tocó incluso cambiar la
presentación iba a ser antes porque yo
no tenía carreras y ahora las tengo
Entonces ahora tenemos un par de meses
para prepararnos para la próxima una
carrera que precisamente será en Francia
en Paul ricard y bueno Esperemos que que
durante el año hayamos mejorando que es
siempre Mostrar progresiones lo más
importante destacas mucho el papel de la
llegada de Karol g a tu carrera
recientemente Y en este libro cuentas
que llegó cuando más lo necesitabas Cuál
era el momento por el que pasabas yo me
quedé sin patrocinadora final de del año
pasado
estaba corriendo la indicar en Estados
Unidos y
pues cuando uno no está activo yo había
dejado varias oportunidades por esa de
estar en la indicar porque había sido
uno de mis sueños estar compitiendo ahí
y pues llego Karol G y su equipo de
trabajo que además Son son varias
mujeres su hermana que es un manager
Jessica para darme la mano y poder
seguir compitiendo esta vez en la
Fórmula 2
seguir soñando y creo que cuando un
apoyo de una persona que uno admira
tanto una latinoamericana colombiana
para mí es como una motivación extra el
mensaje de empoderamiento que ya también
quiso dar con ese apoyo y el hecho de
seguir vinculada con conmigo ya hay
mucha gente en las carreras que me
llamaba bichota y muchas niñas que que
llegan con con sus camisetas de bichota
con el pelo rojo es un movimiento
espectacular de empoderamiento entonces
Más allá de todo ese apoyo el poder
continuar con ese movimiento es algo muy
bonito
Karol G que era una palabra que no
existía en femenino hiciste solamente
masculino y de ahí que ella se inventara
ese término bichota me hablas de seguir
soñando y ya para terminar sigue ese
sueño de competir en la Fórmula 1 Sí yo
creo que
Uno nunca sabe cuándo les llegan las
oportunidades al final yo creo que estoy
preparada para dar ese salto a la
fórmula uno no sé si la fórmula uno esté
preparada para mí y cuando ellos quieran
estaré yo ahí al pie del cañón seguir
soñando Porque si la vida me ha enseñado
algo Es que cuando menos se lo esperas
te llega se alinean los planetas y te
lleva las oportunidades Qué hace falta
para que en la fórmula uno quepa este
Tatiana Calderón yo creo que hace falta
más mujeres al final quien me dio a mí
la oportunidad de ser piloto de
desarrollo del equipo souther fue una
mujer y hoy en día no hay ninguna Team
principal en Fórmula 1 no hay nadie de
los directivos que sea mujer y al final
creo que se necesita ese tipo de apoyo a
veces para que le den a uno la
oportunidad de mostrar lo que puede
hacer y desafortunadamente Pues no ha
venido
de un hombre todavía dar esa oportunidad
que siga soñando que soñemos todos todas
Gabriela Tatiana Muchas gracias por este
tiempo con nosotros la invitación para
que lean este libro la niña más veloz
que el viento una historia muy bonita
muy motivadora Muchísimas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros
a usted muchas gracias por compartir la
historia gracias a ustedes también por
haber estado con nosotros quédense aquí
en la pantalla de France 24 la
información continua Aquí también en
France 24 punto com